hey guys Lisa here with a
post-apocalyptic gamespot news update
the Doomsday Clock has reached 0 and
Bethesda have dropped the bomb fallout 4
is officially coming grab your pit boys
and get them ready because here are the
first details war never changes the
game's official site went live slightly
early ahead of schedule today revealing
that the newest entry in the open world
RPG series will be shipping on pc xbox
one and playstation 4 so if you still
haven't moved over current gen i guess
now is the time as indicated by leaked
documents a couple of years ago fallout
4 will be taking place in boston in the
trailer you can briefly see scollay
square the USS Constitution which is
docked in the city and the Boston
Statehouse no word on the bar from
cheers though bethesda game studios todd
howard who has previously worked on the
Elder Scrolls series and fallout 3 is
directing the project he said we know
what this game means to everyone the
time and technology have allowed us to
be more ambitious than ever we've never
been more excited about a game and we
can't wait to share it the trailer
follows a dog that the internet is
currently going wild over and it flits
between pre and post nuclear disaster
with a voice on the radio setting the
stage for another post apocalyptic
adventure at the end of the trailer
we're introduced to a vault hunter who
says let's go pal to the dog possibly
indicating that the protagonist of
Fallout 4 will be voiced for the very
first time in the series let's go pal so
there it is Bethesda are due to host
their very first III press conference on
june the 14th so join us then as we'll
be seeing more fallout 4 in action and
speaking off what do you think of the
reveal are you hyped or are you gutted
that it's not coming to last gen let me
know in the comments section below and
of course for all the latest on fallout
4 keeper gamespot